hello guys uh welcome to now playing of
call of duty black ops 3 uh the
multiplayer beta we have a early a
slightly early look i think there's
other people as well but i'm eric tay
that's mike mchardy how are you doing
this morning mike
i'm pretty good eric how are you
doing uh all right i'm a little bit lack
of sleep i was uh trying to max out this
character but uh here we are in a match
um you're playing as one of the uh final
specialists that we're able to unlock i
believe his name is hive if i remember
correctly
um and we'll show you his a little
special ability later specialists is one
of the kind of newer things
in this version of call of duty did you
want to talk a little bit more about
that yeah so there are about what eight
characters a little more
something around that maybe eight eight
to ten and they kind of dictate what
special abilities you use and each of
them has two
and obviously i'm not doing too well
right now it's a warm-up game yeah and
um
so right now we're using nomad and one
of his which you can see at the bottom
right the meter charges up and he plants
these traps that kind of
uh emit these
just defensive drones kind of that kill
people i guess
but there are a lot of different
abilities from
sparrow has this
like long bow that shoots explosive
arrows um and you can get perks that
decrease the time it takes to
um
charge up
right nice
you're right it's a nomad not uh
hive i butchered that one and the
ability is hive right but you know
um but yeah so it's very much like
advanced warfare in terms of traversal
the maps are
vertical i mean there are different
height like sight lines depending on
your height and whatnot
you know you have the power slide double
jump
and still perks that kind of
decrease the time it takes to charge
that
i like the map so far i think there are
about
three you can play in the beta right now
yeah i think you're right it's either
three or four
i'm kind of it's like all blur now whoa
i mean at the end of the day like
it's still call of duty game of course
like you know like
one of my actual biggest pet peeves is
like i s like the spawning in this game
is still kind of jank
yeah like
we uh yeah yesterday we were getting
there were a few times when we kind of
got spawn camp for a bit before it
switched sides but also
yeah i don't know it's i there's been
times when i spawn and i'm
looking at the backs of other like the
enemy players
i am also looking at chat so if you guys
have any questions um we'll try to do
our best to answer them
yesterday was the first time i actually
played it i didn't actually get to play
it at like e3 or anything
um
but yeah like another thing like you
said like the wall running and the
grappling and stuff like that one of the
big deals is that
you can kind of do everything while
you're doing that so you should you know
you can still shoot you can reload and
all that stuff
um i think it's interesting i'm not used
to it yet i think it's gonna take you
know some some time for people to get
adjusted to that yes there's also
swimming someone shot me underwater is
the only one
map so far i think there's water
yeah cause the other maps have those
bottomless pits you fall down um maybe
not bottomless but you die when you fall
down yeah because they it's kind of like
here you want to wall run this
yeah but right now these are the this is
the only one that has water
so that slide is still just as useful as
everyone trying to escape from someone
so like i think the interesting thing
too is that if you're sprinting and then
you like you can't really just dolphin
dive anymore like in the past because
then you would do the slide right right
yes
you'd have to be kind of like either
jogging or whatever
oh almost
so that red so she just used that so
so that was
um i thought that was sparrow must have
been around somewhere
unless that was
yeah that's her special ability where
she kind of does a vision pulse yeah so
sparrow's alternate aside from the
longbow is that vision pulse which is
really helpful it shows you exactly
where they are but you have to be close
and it only lasts for about
like two seconds oh damn it
it's okay it's a bait
ah you got it there we go okay so that
was helpful so you guys can get to see
the cool effect from it but what happens
is
i'll probably run into one and then we
can see it
you think i don't think anyone else is
28 in this game though right oh right
he's the yeah he's the top one so thanks
to you
yeah
so
you lay down traps essentially
that have these like nano
bees essentially and if your opponent
walks over them
it basically swarms them and like the
trailer like it'll eat the limbs off
like i've died to it a bunch of times
yesterday and it's actually pretty cool
um i saw some guy drop like five uh
little like traps though so i'm not
really sure
how come you're only able to get one
off there but at least you didn't die
which is the most
but maybe it
i know i i wasn't watching the timer on
your super
can you show it tight
uh we can definitely show it later i
don't know if you can switch specialists
i thought that was like a titanfall joke
or a destiny
i guess there's a lot of titans nowadays
you know
call it this this version of call of
duty actually
in my opinion it's definitely bothering
some of those ideas or borrowing sorry
borrowing those ideas from both games
well because yeah the first
couple specialists you get have very
i mean the the titan that the jump they
can do is kind of like the first
specialist you get right yeah ruin yeah
roon has the gravity spikes which is
essentially very similar to like a titan
smash in destiny and then i unlocked the
serif
who uh one of her special abilities is
the annihilator which is kind of like a
golden gun
it doesn't have the cool golden gun
effect but it does the same thing it's
like a one shot kill like with a strong
magnum i think you get like six bullets
uh it does have a timer of course so you
can't just like wait around with it but
it's got a pretty big hitbox too
yeah i want to try that out
being a hunter fan in destiny
uh is the is the beta just team
deathmatch no it's not but they have a
few modes yeah but for all the modes are
available but it's like for whatever
reason it's like day one call of duty
again where everyone just plays
deathmatch first i uh i think chris
waters got into one kill confirmed match
yesterday i tried and waited for about
15 minutes and could not because i'm a
fan of that mode but yeah
many people are playing it barely
yeah it's just hard to get enough people
in the other modes i think today we'll
kind of see more people now because we
did have it a little bit earlier
yesterday um a lot of uh
you know influencers streamers and
whatnot they should have it today i'm
sure there's a bunch of people streaming
ernest lee actually right there i think
he works for twitch he actually does the
race i don't know if you're familiar
with that but uh every time a call of
duty comes out like him and a bunch of
buddies like hold up in a house and they
try to like prestige like crazy and just
take shifts long shifts
um
but yeah this beta does come out
tomorrow i believe for the public yeah
if you pre-ordered
uh and also we're doing a giveaway
i think i believe that's u.s only for
beta keys
uh i'm
a terrible person and i don't have the
actual link but i will give it to my
producer at some point and he can put it
up on the screen and hopefully you guys
can join in on that
kind of show you the different
specialists right here so that's nomads
what we were just using as of now that's
the highest one you can unlock in the
beta
that i know of at least or that yeah i
didn't see anyone higher than 28
yesterday
not everything's unlocked so like all
the specialists
aren't unlocked yet you have to earn
some of them with levels um just some of
the weapons and stuff yeah go for it i
have both perks okay so i'll be i'll go
with the
annihilator but yeah so here's sarah she
has the golden gun we're talking about
as well as um this one actually seems
really helpful the uh all scorn
pretty much gets you to score streaks
faster
um
and we have a pretty high score streak
equipped right now which
hopefully we get to it would be cool i
haven't seen it i like
i look at it as it
it's not necessarily the goliath from
advanced warfare because you got into
that suit this one's either one that
follows you and protects you or i think
you can just remote control it and walk
it around
um so that's kind of cool uh it would be
amazing if we could get that no idea if
we can but if we do that would be sick
i'll use that creative class i just did
just unlock the burst rifle four round
burst rifle
scene around the same map again but
hopefully we'll get a new one soon yeah
i mean there is only three this is uh
one of the bigger ones of the three i
would say
um
it's a lot of
you know housing and like long sight
lines so this is this map i guess
compared to the other two was
a decent one for sniping um
all right okay so this gun's pretty i
like it i've always
liked the m16 in modern warfare first
one gun yeah yeah wrong way overpowered
one i use it all the time with the red
dot scope
uh this is psn i believe psn
data early compared to xbox one this
time around since they have that
exclusive
thank you all so much
i did not see a hardcore kill confirmed
mode but uh as of now i don't know
yeah this i mean this map not so much
but the other ones especially evac i
think it's called has a lot of
places i mean every time i rounded a
corner i was kind of more worried about
looking up i mean advanced warfare the
same thing their maps were designed to
have some verticality as opposed to the
earlier games but this seems like it's
pushing that even farther which i like
but it doesn't feel completely different
so
still nice it's still yeah i think they
wanted to tone it down a little bit but
still have some of that you know like
the boost you have like you know you can
see that you can do it twice essentially
yeah like you can do one slide and a
boost and you there's a perk that makes
it recharge faster as well
but uh so i don't like i know you
haven't played the last two specialists
you're playing one of them now like out
of the you know the first couple
who's kind of like your favorite so far
i i like sparrow it's the first one i
used and then i unlocked a few other
ones but i used the longbow for a while
and it was
it's it's good i mean like you said you
found out last night you don't have to
charge the bow as long as you thought
you can kind of feather it and it'll if
you hit them it there the arrows will
explode afterward
but
i actually kind of like her other
ability the vision
what's it called provision pulse yeah
vision pulse and it doesn't last for a
long time but it is super helpful
especially in close quarters when you're
kind of just rounding corners and
whatnot
is that one uh like
do you feel like the charge time for
that is faster than like her bow or um i
think it was the same time hers are kind
of long in general it might have been a
little longer i'm not positive but
there we go yeah so that house is like a
big point of contention yeah like so far
every time i've played
because you know gives you a good
vantage point on both
hmm sides burst though yeah and if you
saw those grenades that was the uh i
guess other special
golden gun
nice use it up here i don't know what i
want to run up oh yeah so
hopefully so this is when the spawn
starts
got that guy
all right
this is the annihilator
so he has a pretty big hit box um it's a
one shot one kill
or you could just get health care health
health health storm fired
um that's the worst screw that one up
the whole team tax crowded
i don't think so zero uh zero f's given
basically saying that he doesn't like
the special abilities uh having like you
know one shots
uh he thinks he's gonna ruin the game uh
i think for casual mode i think it's
fine i think it's perfectly fine i think
you can still kill them you have to be
somewhat accurate um to pull these off
and there is a timer so it's not super
overpowered and they do have that picks
and bands mode yeah that will kind of
stop some of that if you're they're
looking at something more competitive
yeah i'm looking forward to
trying that out because that i think
will add a little more depth like in the
pre-game
stages but in a game like this
especially team deathmatch when the time
to kill is so fast i don't know that
the one-hit kills are completely
offsetting anything i mean they're
definitely
power they're definitely more powerful
but
not to such an extent that i think it's
ruining anything yeah
and i'd say about
you kind of use the abilities maybe
three times a match and unless you have
perks or unless you're
yeah unless they're just faster
recharging ones
i think it's also one of those things
like that's a kind of a trend in in kind
of shooters now it's like
how do they
make the player feel even more powerful
i think special abilities and whatnot is
what kind of
you know obviously makes you slightly a
little bit more powerful gives you that
satisfaction of like okay i got the
annihilator up i think i got a triple at
one point and i was just like oh this is
sick
like
yeah one i really want to show actually
soon is glitch
it's profit one of his abilities
what's his other one i forget it's a
tempest he's got the like lightning gun
which um
it has a small charge up time once it
hits the guy it's a one shot and then
anyone that gets near him actually will
get shocked as well
okay nice here you go um play a little
slower yeah
um but oh so anyway glitch um profits
ability essentially it
you just you
warp backwards about 10 feet from where
you just were and if you do it fast
enough people can't hurt you there's i
think there's like a split second of
invulnerability but if you use it right
you can kind of like say i'm rounding
this corner and stuff like this i could
have i mean if he was about to kill me i
could have used it right there and
jumped back here and then lined up
another shot um we were playing with uh
yesterday rob hanlery he
him and i were kind of running around a
corner and someone was about to shoot
him he used it so then oh damn it
yeah um
he used it so i finished the person off
so it's kind of good for um
distractions as well if you use i could
see people using it to pretty do some
pretty cool things
nice
but i like it a lot and try to show that
next yeah um so someone asked in chat i
think is
blade kl sorry if i butchered your name
uh does this play like advanced warfare
uh like slightly a little bit slower
though right because not so much
boosting all over the place yeah i think
it's um i kind of controlled yeah it
feels advanced warfare felt more like
titanfall than this
but there's still the same verticality
as far as kind of jumping and using
rooftops
use that water escape
so this part's kind of i mean like i
it's kind of interesting you know you
can't shoot underwater also it's like
these are like these little pathways
that you can use to kind of navigate the
map so that you don't just get
you know seen all the time
um i've seen people use it to get to the
house and whatnot so that's
kind of cool i guess um to answer the
question i think it
it's definitely like modern warfare i
think or sorry advanced warfare i think
they're building off it but it's
i don't think it's as fast pace but it's
still
you know call of duty speed
um but yeah it's the same kind of
you know
up down as much as like lateral movement
as advanced warfare was um
but they still have the it's like a pick
10. people want you to do some more
running okay i'll do some wall running
but like my response to that though too
is like yeah the wall running is in the
game but i think if you played enough
call of duty games it's just like
in your blood that you don't necessarily
do that because usually it doesn't gain
you that much i mean sometimes it does
like sometimes you can make some sick
plays and you'll get like triples or
doubles because you did some nice
movement that you know the opponent
really think you do but
yeah at the end of the day it's call of
duty and you're still going to kind of
play it like mechanically i still see
people head camp a bunch you know like
they're just like behind barrels or like
you know like low um
in good favorable spots and whatnot
yeah so
um
yeah because so rob again rob handler
yesterday we were playing he was using a
shotgun and he was kind of using wall
run to stay above people and then drop
down on them but anytime i saw someone
wall running it was kind of just
i shot them right away and you have to
be there is the perk that lets you shoot
while while running and sprinting and
everything but
you have to be pretty good to do it
and i don't i'm not that good so i'll do
my best too no worries i mean you can
just show it to the best of your ability
so this is profit i'm going to try
glitch out to show people that
uh quarter life in the game spot chat
how are we playing beta we have it early
there are some people that have it early
today um you know other media outlets
probably some youtubers some
twitch streamers you'll be seeing it on
twitch
you know for the general public if you
pre-ordered the game you will have
access tomorrow which is wednesday um so
yeah look forward to that if you you
know
pre-load it i think you can pre-load it
already
zombies is not in this i think i already
said that but if i didn't just in case
so this is actually a good map to wall
run on because there are these interiors
that you can kind of
and then there's this like one spot in
the middle of the map where you're like
i want to wall run this and then
sometimes like it doesn't pick you up
like right down there i've wall ran like
near the edge of it and it just scooped
me up oh okay
but yeah like
you like i said earlier you can like
like even as you like vault over that
you can in scary shoot which is like a
big deal um
i haven't used it too much the wall
running stuff's kind of cool when you
actually get the opportunity for it to
like work out where you know sometimes
you're wall running the other guy's wall
running and you just happen to shoot and
he doesn't and he just dies and you're
like okay yeah and then you just keep
wall running
i have killed someone vaulting over
something um it's you know harder but
it's definitely feels
i don't feel as
in danger as i used to when i was
vaulting we can try the snipers later i
like the second one better than the
first one the lotus is kind of hard i'm
not really great at that one i'll let
you play this sniper i'll try um
there is that map
voting excuse me guys uh so every time
it ends you know you get to pick one or
two or just random uh currently there's
only three maps so you're probably going
to see a lot of the like similar maps
this is a pretty popular one
you almost cut it off i think i still
have oh it didn't sound sweet
so that would have been a good time to
use it if i okay so that was bad but i
still got out of the open i guess but
it would have been a good time because
then you i could have just jumped back
and then rounded the corner again
take some time to get used to but
i like this map though this is one of
those there's like a lot of
and now after the
death screen you can see how many times
you've died to that person and it'll say
you know he's your nemesis because he's
killed you five times and you just get
more salty yep and yeah that person
killed me a few times yeah well he's
chilling in that spot waiting for you
guys to spawn essentially that's why
he's smart because
yeah
because that's one of those back routes
i like to take out of there
was that him yeah it was him nice and
you uh so you got a little bit more
points there because i think he
triggered his special yeah killed him
when he wasn't special and a king slayer
so he must have been either on a streak
or he's their top player yeah i think
king slayer is top player okay
okay so
yeah see this spawn point always is the
tough one
i feel like they're more there's more uh
collision over on this side of the map
than
so glitch has a pretty decent recharge
yeah because it's not as offensive
as of a special ability i guess so
it is pretty annoying though because
like like you said yesterday rob was
using with the shotgun and every time i
was like oh i'm gonna kill him he would
time it right and then he would just
warp back and like oh son of a bee yeah
they're definitely those players that
will get really good with it
assist nope
nice
headshot
yeah so if you're good with headshots um
this game will reward you for it yeah
okay so i had glitch so i probably used
that at some point during all that
fiasco it's kind of hard to remember it
all though you keep
and yeah the thing i mean again being
call of duty it's
the power-ups are great and they're they
change up what you do a little bit but
it's still call of duty you can kill
someone within half a second if you want
so there's always still just you know
twitch reflexes involved
and i hate running through here i don't
know why i keep going through it yeah
especially with the gun you have yeah
you're just waiting to get
like smg'd
i will say that sometimes like i think
it's
like
i don't want to say net code but it's
like internet connectivity like
sometimes you it's like the old call of
duty thing where like sometimes you
think like how did he kill me like i
shot him first and then like he's
watching replay and he's like oh okay
yeah
a little bit of latency but yeah
especially when you're when i do that
you know just slide away from them they
still kill me even though it yeah you're
like you're around the corner like what
you think is it the kill cam is always
not always representative of what really
looked like from their point of view
i'm sorry
the kill cam always shows you a little
more of what they saw which doesn't
always line up with what it looked like
when you died
get that revenge
yeah
what if this personally uav inbound
yeah so it's like
sometimes they'll say like
i think it's like
the class they're playing away i'm not
sure okay but they make those call outs
a bunch
it's actually funny when they they talk
like post game screen like one of the
you know like maybe the first place
person you hear the voice
bio armor like
so you can see how that's really useful
when you use it right
but it's one of those things you kind of
have to be
ready to use it's not i mean after a
while i'm sure you
you'll uh it'll become a reflex but
right now it's clearly not for me
yeah i mean everyone's going to kind of
find their um
more favorite specialist
and you know you're going to
either play glitch a lot or you know
circumstances oh so that's a sparrow
right now just almost shot with a bow
circumstance might dictate like who you
play like
uh rune does have like over charge i
think or overdrive
it's one of the other things uh which
allows you to run faster which
will probably be good for like uplink
you know like you're going to want one
guy on your team that's always got that
ability so that they can run the ball or
run the flag
yes i'm not normally like a
short range kind of player and i don't
know why i keep running through there
because you know that people want action
okay so i got glitch see if i can make
this work again all right uh there's a
question in chat uh how many shots to
kill
um
is it similar to
ghost um
it actually we all kind of noticed
yesterday it feels a little longer i
mean advanced warfare itself was
slightly longer but this feels
definitely on the longer side still
quick but it's not i would say it's not
ghost was i think pretty
fast from what i remember yeah
i mainly agree sometimes i die really
fast i'm not really sure why and it's
not always because of like a head shot
necessarily like head shot of course
you're just going to die pretty much
outright so
if you're uh you know got good aim
here's sparrow right yeah so this is
so if he's pretty charged up if he was
in the doorway he would have launched
back about 15 feet and it's kind of cool
because it can turn him into a grenade
um
yeah it's
for call of duty i think it's slightly
longer than i'm used to in my most my
experiences but um
as opposed to ghosts i think it's a
little longer
i want you to try some other weapons
okay
um shotgun snipers
i'll try a sniper if they're asking for
snipers earlier
if you want to use the second one which
is a little bit easier i already have
that one uh oh that's fine the recons
the dragon
so it's like a this sniper is
interesting because it's got a 20 clip
i want to say if you get like upper mass
it is one shot but it's like
semi-automatic so you can keep shooting
it okay um it kind of felt like the
what's that one gun the m1
8a or something like that yeah something
about like that i i butchering that but
it's like a single shot
and that you can kind of spam and it's
actually pretty strong like you don't
even have to really hold your breath if
you don't want to
um unless you're like really far away
like i feel like medium range you can
kind of just like
scope and bang bang and keep shooting
and you can follow them too it's pretty
pretty fast
i'm so waiting for people here show
specialists right now so that's sparrow
or outrider this is the sparrow bow
i didn't see any
like character customization i know that
there's paints for guns but i didn't see
anything crazy for the uh
the specialists at all yet so here's the
paint shop
so what gun am i using right now see if
you did anything with that
you can create new paints um
throw these kind of symbols on it
and do uh yeah
durka fish um
it's not as fast-paced as aw
it's not necessarily in line with black
ops 2 i think it's somewhere in the
middle yeah that's how i feel like it's
like a toned down aw
yeah to give him credit it does feel
more like black ops um
like as far as being part of the black
ops you know trilogy now yeah but
definitely faster than
the first two yeah
which i was a big fan of black ops 2
with that i was too pick 10 system when
they introduced it was great
they still kind of have it here i don't
yeah they don't necessarily like pick 10
but like it's kind of similar like you
can
load up on your gun but you lose your
nays you know maybe you're secondary you
can load up on perks if you want um just
depends on how you want to play it yeah
and so that's
that
do another paint
so see how i do a sniper rifle maybe
i'll get a good
good man
making a real nice gun here
covering up your line even it's like a
camo on top of the line
i don't think there's we don't have any
camos right there's no cameras to show i
don't think so yeah i think the only
thing we were able to customize was
painting your gun um your emblems right
now are locked they seem to just
kind of populate when you level up and
yeah because they just change while you
level up
that disappeared looks like this is the
only area i can put this on
yeah i think you can spin it around you
might be able to get it on the the
stockish area
not positive on that one
i expect there to be a lot of dumb
looking guns
yeah definitely coming in the future
so we saw a glitch
would be a good long-range
character to use not ruin i
sparrow
this not so much just because you have
to we're out of tokens anyways you spent
all my tokens man can you earn some
tokens now
can we if we're max level i don't that's
a good question i probably should have
thought about that before i spent them
uh i could use golden gun
um
not a big deal
i'll use uh the war machine the grenade
launcher
you need fire support
she seems to be decent with a long range
yeah i like serif quite a bit i i do
want to try nomad
the the bee thing is pretty cool yeah
yeah the um i don't i think i really
like glitch because when you use it
right if you feel
pretty badass like you saw i almost used
it right but
luckily
for them i guess their other teammate
was kind of ready for it or saw it from
far away it's pretty easy to predict
where they're going to jump to because
when you're up close it's just this blue
light um
i think we got pretty good footage of it
yesterday but
that's the best so snark axe snark x
sorry asked about tokens and what i mean
by tokens it's like currency you earn
that then allows you to unlock
specialists specialist abilities
guns
perks so those require tokens you get
those like as you level i think as you
do achievement type stuff and you've
gotten one from like getting
people with like the like a kill streak
or something like that and it's just one
per rank i believe at least for the few
i did yeah i haven't seen anything cost
more than one i mean there's enough
stuff to buy already so
um
yeah
okay
got a match so
do team deathmatch again we could try at
some point again the other ones maybe
there will be enough people to
play
hardcore or kill confirmed or something
no there's alex rubins
yeah i saw him last night too yeah so
it's it's interesting to be able to play
a little bit earlier because you see a
lot of like pro players and stuff like
that you're like oh there's optic diesel
and there's like they're all much better
than me than i am at least oh yeah they
were they're killing me too i just like
to try to trade with them
to the best of my ability
for anyone that keeps asking about how
we're able to play we have it early um
there's a lot of um i think media
outlets that have it early a lot of
streamers that have it early um
youtubers that have it early so we just
have it a day early you guys can watch
it sorry that you guys can't play it but
you will be able to play it tomorrow
if you've pre-ordered
and i think we're also doing a giveaway
i'm a terrible person because i didn't
give my producer the actual link
hopefully they're working on that but
there is a giveaway for us only i'm
sorry europe and the rest of the world
but i think you can go in there and try
to win a beta from there as well
show some score streaks while we're
waiting for the match to begin here nope
never mind well that was the gi unit um
that's the robot we were talking about
that either follows you around you said
or it's not it's not the exo it's not
the the mech from advanced yeah it's not
like the goliath from what i can tell
from the tooltip or the mantis and halo
whatever i guess a lot of games have
those yeah it just sounded like
it's it's kind of like the talon which
was another killstreak which is like a
drone which either follows you and
patrols with you and then just tries to
protect you
or you can just lay on the ground and
like hold the square and take control of
it and have it walk around or fly around
however you want
so this map is actually not terrible to
use a sniper on actually yeah it is kind
of
but we'll see yeah i don't really ever
feel comfortable sniping on that last
map you're on um
which is not hunted i think it's combine
hunt it's okay too actually this one's
i feel like really there's a lot of
corridors and a lot of close quarters
there's like three main avenues you kind
of go up in this one the center and the
right and left and then other than that
it's
kind of just
yeah not great for sniping i'll try it
out anyway though
hopefully i can show you something with
this
like this spot right here me and rob the
moment we got this gun like we were just
happy you can actually just like just go
okay so i was i thought it would might
have been like yeah no you can just like
you can just go to town like i mean
relative to how fast the gun will shoot
but you can spam it okay essentially so
that's good to know i might have like
the fal yeah i remember right yeah it's
like the fal
oh so it's got a long yeah
fl was crazy though because i remember
you could get it to like have full
bursts
or something when it shouldn't have been
full auto yeah and that was more of a
like semi-auto rifle so this is kind of
a mid-range sniper
um
yeah we'll try to show off some of the
other specialists here in a bit um
i know you have a better experience with
the bow than i do so i'll probably have
you yeah so right now we're using um get
the grenade launcher hopefully oh nice
yeah that one's pretty fun because if
they like get near you you just insta
give them and they just turn into
giblets yeah
so hopefully
i mean the
the specialist abilities charge up
throughout
i actually haven't used that gun the
burst uh hand cannon i really liked the
burst
pistol in uh modern warfare 2 you could
put a red dot on it i figured it was
called but i always had decent levels
with my sniper loadouts just because
i don't know it was a little easier to
kill him in close range than with the
regular pistol but as you can see it's
you know has the burst so it's look like
a two shot essentially like yeah i'd say
the same thing as that a saw rifle i was
just using
yeah this is a this is a usually a spot
of high contention yeah because then
there's this tunnel to the left which
goes right toward the center
battery
hard it's definitely hard at short range
with the uh yeah i say the best sniping
map so far was that first one we played
wall running oh you're good
there we go
so that was a good way to escape i guess
yeah it's a decent way to traverse the
map too
you could even jump off to the middle
area where
you're talking about earlier from that
spot or just go all the way
across yeah
it is kind of sketchy though when you do
that because if someone sees you while
running sometimes it's kind of hard to
like aim at that person yeah because
they kind of have leverage on you so
it's good and bad
ah ooh we did a little dolphin yeah no
dive just a little dolphin there
i used to be able to do that i can't i
don't have the reflexes to do that
anymore and i think it's easier for
people that play claw
yeah you you and i both don't appear to
play claws
this is not a great place to be at all
it's fine
okay all right so i have war machine can
use that
this actually seems like a decent map to
do it on let's see if i can get a sniper
kill first
it may look like advanced warfare but
it's really not
um i mean
you'll know once you play it it's harder
to
show it i guess yeah so that right there
was a very modern warfare encounter he
did the burst to get up there and then i
kind of
thought he was down again but yeah but i
feel like in modern warfare he would
have he would have did the burst to jump
up and then he would have like side
boosted too yeah like after the fact
like oh [ __ ] i can't win this so i side
boost but like in this game it's harder
i don't think there is a side boost at
all there is a side dash but you need to
have momentum to do that because i mean
speaking of shoot like shooters that
have kind of followed in titan falls
awake halo 5 has a lot of those
traversal mechanics coming up when it
comes on what october yeah and that has
a lot of those side boosts at the
gym okay so
what oh
so i think someone did ask earlier about
what that uh like radar ping on the the
map was and what it is is that we have a
perk on that yeah called awareness or
sixth sense sixth sense i think that if
there's any enemy nearby you'll get the
ping
of course there's ways to counter that
as well i believe you just have to have
the right counter perks there's always
in every good call of duty game there's
always a counter to something else so
so i'll use war machine once i uh
right now
bam so that was a direct hit
so normally what would happen too is
like if you didn't get directed it drops
those three grenades yeah which is still
super help like a little cluster bomb
yeah it could be this like war machine
could be like one of those really good
things for um like domination or
hardpoints like they're all on there or
whatever you just want to clear them out
i really like uh war machine
but yeah as you can see it's like i mean
i do like the specialist abilities
because
you can kind of either use their
abilities to supplement the kind of play
style you do and the class you have or
kind of balance it out like right now
i'm doing
it works pretty well i'm like i have a
mid-range sniper rifle but i'm also kind
of balancing that out with a burst
pistol but then the war machine itself
gives me more just
you know
area damage or just direct one-hit kills
yeah i mean like as you play and like
depending on the modes you know and
depending on if you're playing with your
friends or whatnot you're definitely
gonna see like you know multiple
different loadouts you know like hey you
should go this or that and then i'll go
this or that and then you know yeah
so as you can see that was that was the
disadvantage there like you couldn't
even really see him i guess you could
turn to look for him which i yeah i'm
not training up with the
i don't know why i
ran in there that was tempest yeah
tempest
is also pretty good i mean
he just went to town he just killed a
lot of people that so that's prophet's
other ability which just shocks
it hits
the person you're aiming at obviously
with the electricity but then it
channels to other people
if they're close enough
yeah
it's also good to note uh melee doesn't
kill one shot anymore in the front
you've got to do it twice unless you're
right behind that once you have the perk
there you need a combat knife oh sorry
not is it a it's an item you can slot a
combat knife yeah so right now it's just
a pistol whip yeah or you know
right hit the bar the rifle but
i almost got to show you that gun
yeah obviously missed
so someone as you can see that thing
just
my sixth sentence went off it's showing
me someone nearby he's dead
they're against the wall
oh my god
almost
grenade
especially when paired with a grenade
right afterward
a few more
classes um you were using i don't know
what's your favorite specialist so far
do you have a favorite ability
i so i was in this mode where i was just
trying to like get through a lot of it
um serif is pretty fun
i don't know if i'm the like most
accurate person in terms of like
using the the bow and arrow or the
golden gun i feel like sometimes i can
pull it off other times you know
it doesn't pan out so
i would say profit with tempest was
pretty fun
i do like serif because of that ability
i would love to get the gi unit even
though that probably seems unlikely yeah
um
but we'll see
yeah i mean it's
just learning the specialist classes i
think is pretty important not
so all the way not so much as just you
using them but knowing
what they do so if someone else has it
you kind of know what to expect
like if i run into profit i know they've
been using glitch i think that could
help me in the future if they're going
to more backwards i kind of just you
know you need overwatch i'll try to use
sparrow we'll see how it goes
yeah so people asking it's just strictly
multiplayer in the beta there's no
zombies or anything yet which the zombie
mode looks like they're doing that weird
storyline which looks pretty cool like i
mean as far as trying to make the
zombies fresh again um
um customization for your characters as
of now there's not the only aesthetic is
guns because other than that you just
see which specialist class they are
um so obviously you see a lot of um
outriders here using the sparrow
uh and vision pulse
um but other than that if you see their
appearance is based entirely on what
specialists they're using this match
yeah i mean i honestly wouldn't be
surprised if you didn't really see too
much of it because they're you know they
want to keep the specialist pretty pure
i'm assuming but who knows maybe you can
get like a different advice or something
yeah but they all look pretty unique
that's why i feel like they might not
you know change it but
who knows
i will attempt to snipe so this map
seems like it'd be better for it yeah so
usually they're gonna come from there or
there
oh there's one
oh and i'm a scrub
i saw two yeah i saw two and i was like
oh maybe if i get this guy quick i can
get the other guy but you know instead i
just i should have just held my breath
which i did not do that's after playing
like once i get really into each call of
duty game like um
the last call of duty game i i mean i
liked i
thought advanced warfare was a great
addition to the franchise just as far as
how much it changed even in the campaign
i thought but
um
one thing i'll do in multiplayer after a
while if i'm if it's two on one i'll
immediately just try to run away and get
to cover because i know i'm not good
enough to kill both of them in most
cases if they're both looking right at
me i'm just gonna get out of there um
you know
they're not spawned
they wanted to see wall running so i can
do that
so asking how long the beta will be live
for um once everyone gets their codes i
think it's 23rd right yeah i think it's
until the 23rd which is sunday would it
be midnight on that night or um yeah
oh oh i thought there's a frag
so it is one shot like high in the like
chest area so yeah this is the same
rifle i was just using just a different
scope this is a
looks like a more
kind of mid-range mine was a little
shorter for a sniper
although mine was variable zoom
i'm worried that they're going to play
no
see old call of duty i would have panic
knifed him
so yeah i have killed people with the
melee but i've kind of gotten a shot on
them first before i did it
i'd say spare nice i'd say the outrider
couples well with sniper rifles just the
sparrows are pretty can be a pretty long
range weapon
um
yeah you can charge up well i'll wait
until you get it to talk about it
because i really like it
but this map i think is probably one of
my favorites in the beta
yeah it's like i said this one is the
biggest here we'll try to go through
this like waterfall section yeah you
know it's like pretty dangerous
yeah sorry for clarification the beta we
think ends on the 23rd but it begins
tomorrow
correct yeah for um
let's say the people that pre-order
someone did say that if you ordered
deluxe that you got it today which i
have no idea um so yeah tomorrow
wednesday the
19th until the 23rd and then i think uh
26th
to the 30th or something for playstation
or sorry for xbox one and
uh pc sorry it's really hard to like try
to snipe when i suck at sniping as it is
do i try another gun um
this is the mano war uh this is probably
my favorite auto assault rifle sorry i
haven't tried the pulse one or the burst
gun yet but
um playing too much destiny calling it a
pulse rifle yeah
it's my life man
they have geller horn what's left
uh i'm taking care of the gala horn will
be useless
see like in those cases i don't
understand how i lost that but i guess
yeah so
it is what it is
but yeah i'd say it's definitely i mean
if you have access to the beta i'd say
go for it i think at the very least it's
going to get you ready for when the game
comes out i think there are new things
you can learn in the meantime
that might give you the advantage when
it comes out um
like i said again with a base create a
class just based weapons you'll still be
able to kill people it's call of duty so
it's very accessible but
um you know eric played a lot more than
i did last night after we had been
playing for a while during the day so
just trying out all the new specialists
is probably a good incentive to get get
into the beta get up to level 28 right
now we think that's the max um
so
yeah i mean like it also helps you like
figure out what gun you think you're
going to use you know i mean like that
you think you're going to like more with
like less
no idea if there's going to be any
different balance or anything to it but
yeah oh so there's tempest
there you go so see right there those
tempest shutdown you get extra points
for obviously killing people using their
abilities
there's nades everywhere man i'm scared
i will attempt to do this all right
so you can charge up your arrow
indefinitely
if you want to do the launch yeah and
then if you want to cancel i just click
the right stick so you don't waste a
shot
nice
oh see right there i thought that was
gonna be a case where she got launched
into her teammate
there you go come out
oh i almost got the triple with it
yeah so ideally like when it when you're
closer it's like way better to just
feather it because she just has to pluck
it right so
as long as you have a it has decent aim
assist so
you should be able to get them but you
know if they kind of strafe or jump out
of the way it's not going to happen
obviously
it'll be interesting once more people
are playing um you know tomorrow and the
beta is
full on to play like hardcore because i
could see
using s i mean obviously being hardcore
mode i could see using such different
uh
class layouts as far as you know like if
i was using outright or i'd probably use
the vision pulse
vision pulses sounds like it'd be
perfect for hardcore mode
you don't have radars and then you just
light up where they are
because the vision pulse actually when
you see them through the walls that's
what the new spectator mode looks like
um you can kind of see where everybody
is on the map [ __ ] she's right there
yeah and she's vision following me right
now so that's pretty terrifying to see
yourself go red because you know that
they know exactly where you are where
you're facing and
i don't know that i've beaten someone
that's going to tell me when they have
that active it's like man if if he had
fmj there that would have been even
worse
so far i've gotten nothing but shitty
packages from this thing oh great it's a
dart oh no it's a lightning strike i
don't even know what that does um
food stamps turtle was just asking what
they're calling the slot that's
basically the super that's the
specialist we're talking about so you
get to have one selected
as of now there are about eight
specialists nine one that we didn't
unlock
and essentially you pick that class and
they're that specialist and then they
have one
you assign one of two abilities that
they can use
so right now
eric is using the sparrow longbow but
the outrider's other one is the vision
pulse i was just talking about that's
pretty much what that person used
against him and lit him up so you can
see through walls kind of like the uh
spectator mode or
kind of old school the farsight xr20
from perfect heart if you played that a
lot
i did not play that one circumstance
holy crap there was a you were
i could have killed that one guy though
he ran right by me like
that was very disappointing to say
this person with the tempest seems to be
well i thought he had it still
yeah he's kind of just spamming it off
oh that guy's using trying to use golden
gun oh the talon is so beast it's like
this mini drone that you can control
it's like right there it's so annoying
i shouldn't have done that the talon oh
that's the kill streak right square tree
i keep saying kill streak but it's not
place
so the super i'm really interested to
try out for playing later today is the
um
what's the what's the specialist with
the golden gun ability sarah serif i
really want to try that one that gives
you
the shorter times to your
score streaks because that seems like it
could really
maybe we can get that gi unit later
one could only oh no
i hope yeah
what are you guys doing back here come
on
that's like the one benefit i feel like
when you play with friends like i feel
like i can trust my back
yeah i don't have to worry about it but
like when i play
by myself i just feel like i get flanked
all the time oh we won though
yeah so
supply drops there's the one perk that
we have assigned right now we just
haven't been good enough to reach it are
they are they talking about supply drops
like in advanced warfare though with the
boxes um as far as that goes then no but
the
crate drop i think it's called perk that
we are of course score streak that we
have is just the one you call in i mean
it's been in earlier games it gives you
a random one
you know every once in a while you get
something really overpowered in it but
most of times uav counter uav
maybe a hellstorm
uh we'll try
i'll try another specialist
and then i'll try some other weapons
i'll show you guys uh one of the smg's i
like the most which is the razorback i
don't know if you use that that much but
i've i have used it a little bit okay
not a lot yeah it's a nice kind of like
in-between kind of thing um
so for those who were just kind of
signing in recently these are the
specialists this is the screen
so you can see they have two um about to
use this tempest functioning normally
all right so that was war machine that's
the one that i really like
um
there's serif
so there's that ability to get double
the points when the thing is when her uh
that special is active yeah
so if you're really good that's going to
be like crazy yeah streaks definitely
and then nomads got the hive which
like i said it trapped it drops down
like little traps that have like nano
drones in it that swarm you and then he
has reject which is you recover from
death at the same position which i guess
will be more
kind of like specific mode
yes and then this is kind of the titan
guy if your destiny player is uh not a
big fan of that superman no it's because
you killed me once with it yesterday but
i never used it but like
the difference here is like
in destiny uh the titan would actually
have like minor invulnerability
during um
during the smash so that you could
absorb a little bit of damage before
doing it but here it's like you just
don't absorb anything
but yeah you can kind of see
i don't know if razerback's the best on
this map but we'll see i'll try to make
it work
raising back the smg yeah it's like a
nice uh like medium range
um smg that's also good close range of
course but um
this map in particular it's kind of like
one of those maps where you want to have
an assault rifle or a sniper
because it kind of takes a while to get
up close to people
yeah we'll just go yolo into the house
and probably die
yeah i'd say the center the map is
probably the best place to be if you're
using this weapon
there you go
okay so the fire rate's not as high as i
would expect in smg
yeah the damage is pretty good though
i think it's the uh it's the second
assault rifle you unlock the mk3 mx3 uh
i forget what it's called the one he
just i deserve that yeah it's the pretty
high fiery for install rifle
oh i do have a name
stay in the other car
oh someone tried to frag him
with the car
i don't know is there kind of a
comparison is there a comparable
specialist in this to the warlock
the warlock
yeah i mean just as far as you know this
um having kind of the serif being like
uh durability destiny fans
wondering kind of if there's a well
reject is resurrection essentially yeah
so but for yourself or are you right
right yeah yeah
um
yup you got it
that's josh's last game so i better i
better step oh that guy was doing the
wall run right there
um to sneak by you can also do it on
here
but it's awkward uh you almost hit
ah
there they are everywhere okay
it's all right you gotta do you gotta
try to do some crazy plays
hope they work out
oh there's only
oh
that guy when
that one guy wasn't looking man who
woulda
had a two-piece
two-piece special
oh that would have been if you had the
combat knife there that would have been
perfect
i should have tried to melee him anyways
i don't know if it would have killed him
though there's a tempest
oh let's go inside
he's got a hellstorm
you got someone with it crazy quack
nice
so that's where that vaulting was pretty
good especially with smgs which are a
little more
maneuverable
oh i'm so slow
that's why the maneuverability is so
nice because in that situation in older
games you would either go left or right
to kind of do cat and mouse with them
but unless you can jump over and
that's also
all right let's let's try it
get the other guy
why didn't he get the other guy okay get
the other guys
it's probably better at long range just
because you don't have to worry about
them shooting you in the face that is
lame right there i should have i should
have known but i should just shot him to
you
it's okay at least i got the double
oh no i don't know if this is gonna work
that's like oh i didn't have enough
boost
okay so nearby and that's the terrifying
thing you know there's semi close by
because it only works within a certain
range
i think as long as you're sprinting
it'll automatically clean yeah you just
touch the wall and then like friendly
well in most cases it would
this wall
run
oh
that sucked see he got a
random headshot
i would like to think of this random one
and again yeah this is the map with that
underwater traversal which
as of now it's the only one but again
this is the veda
come on someone fight me underwater
can you use it to get into the house
sneak your way in yeah people have come
up through there before hope that they
don't see me which team deathmatch it's
it's nice i mean you can kind of used to
escape and then so he just
kind of watched panic he panicked
grabbed me
or something um but another death in
other game modes like the underwater
could be kind of key to just getting
inside if you're playing like a
dude it's hardpoint coming back is that
in i believe so okay because that'd be
beautiful that or like hardcore and kind
of getting around in a different way
um i will say you're gonna see a lot of
mistakes were made kind of things
because as you try to like traverse the
map and you're like oh i can do this or
i can do that you're gonna just like
fall into it here i'll show you a dumb
one
like this oh
come on man or else i'm trying to show
the stream something real dumb that was
i guess that was dumb yeah no you
succeeded
the way you planned
is there a place you can oh so under the
bridge you mean
uh you can fall off that waterfall oh
okay i don't think i did that i did that
on the evac map i fell into those
pits the very first thing i did in this
beta in this game was jump into one of
those pits and died i was hoping none of
you noticed the uh
emma hardy mistakes were made
notification
everyone makes mistakes
you play this legit while i go and show
the stream something real dumb oh you
can wall run that but then it's like
here if you're just like uncareful oh
wait okay i don't know it i fell down
that last time
um i think you yeah you could just jump
off this bridge if you wanted to
i could
now i don't know if i want to
ruin wasted
the vanquish slide
yeah that's tough to aim down the sights
while you're doing that
it's like that's why having shotguns are
nice you kind of have that hip fired
power and powers
i would like someone to put a uav up
before i use this tempest but i might
not oh someone's wallowing
any duck see like you just die for it
looks like he just
failed and jumped in the water
kill for that gun yeah like it's pretty
good
um
i like it a lot it's kind of like my
go-to i've seen someone use the kuda
which is the starting smg and that
thing's pretty decent
man should we try to flank him
nice
yeah so assist two are a little
interesting um the more damage you do
the more points you get i don't remember
if that's been like that more recently
but like if you did most of the damage
you'll get like 75
whereas you know if you did like one
shot you get 25 so
yeah the scale's nice especially when
you're going for the next score streak
which we haven't really gotten many
today
i just can't keep it together
i think i got one uav i got the care
package
i mean tv fair our third score streak is
1500 points and
yeah
nice
no oh that was pretty good used to that
yeah starts jumping above you when you
get yeah i wonder like how big that
radius is if i can avoid it or not
yeah see so there's a lot of that
there's a lot of like head camping like
you're just gonna see a lot of people
behind boxes and i would say if you're
not like super familiar with call of
duty's you know your best bet is even if
people hate it you can kind of just play
slow um oh
there's two guys in the water swimming
the pool party
i would say just place slower and not
like how i am and running in and dying
all the time
yeah i tend to be sort of
i think my favorite mode i'm more of a
hardcore mode player i really like
not having you know radar right up there
sorry not having just yeah radar right
off the bat when they're shooting but
um yeah team deathmatch is always i mean
you call that car rough though because
it's like any little peck and you're
like dead
it's crazy how much more damage like
you take in hardcore
yeah
you know you're feeling bad when you're
about to have to get it come back
hopefully
every time i look at my score i just end
up worse so don't look at your score
either
yeah i know i've every time i look at
those
scoreboard it just ends up being oh wow
we're about to lose because i think i
fed two main kills
real talk let's see yeah there we go
anyways
let's just erase this game
i can cut this out myself because i can
i can do these kind of things i probably
won't just edit out every death of yours
and put in
every kill
yeah just show me being pretty bad at
the game i mean i i saw some i saw some
people kind of doing that last night too
i think some youtubers were only trying
to like record the really big games
which makes sense because that's what
people want to see
um but yeah that's uh kind of a
like a one-hour look um on the beta for
call of duty black ops 3. we're going to
have more stuff on the site
just trickling throughout the day we've
got um you know i'll try to do like a
gun montage thing that shows you all the
guns uh we're going to try to do some
tip stuff yeah possible written stuff go
up um we might even talk about it on the
lobby who knows
stay tuned to the lobby that's at 2 pm 3
hours from now
but yeah thanks mike for playing and
joining me on this live stream and
thanks everyone else for watching we'll
see you guys next time
later
you